let's face it you have a problem
hoarding happens to everyone in the
wasteland you are not alone I mean come
on
do you really need this cafeteria tray
I'm not gonna allow this stuff to be
thrown in the trap
okay all right how about this empty pink
hand it was in our house is our business
I mean are you really that low on steel
for crafting no daddy
okay okay fine but hear me out I think I
have a solution to all that junk you're
hoarding it's called the junk jet baby
shoot all that [ __ ] you don't need down
the road you might be tight on ammo and
when you're being harassed by a pack of
ghouls this little guy will put those
slimy [ __ ] to shave where is it good
question without spoiling too much
you're looking for the Cambridge police
station which is roughly southeast from
the sanctuary there you'll talk to
paladin dance who will take you on a
quest to the arc jet systems in the
basement of this building you'll find
the junk jet now I'll be the first to
say the junk jet does not excel and
damage which is why it's worth your time
to beef this baby up with mods tack on a
long barrel recoil stock and a Gunners
sight to help improve this beast but the
real kicker are the electrification and
ignition modules these modules add
electricity and fire to your junk
drastically boosting its damage they do
require gun nut perk shrink two and
three so be prepared to put some hours
in for ignition but the real question is
what should you junk well the good news
is that most of time you can pick the
items back up most the time but do
certain items do more damage let's find
out let's start with something soft
dishrag high now shooting at the same
guy here's the cutting board same damage
how about the silver table knife first
toaster
Ruth same deal there you have it it
don't matter the type of junk just junk
it one sentence however what is worth
knowing is that you'll do more damage
not using vats and holding down the
trigger for charged-up shots so when
you're in that lab basement with no ammo
and just a pack of ghouls junk it can't
get down it may not be the best weapon
but hey this baby just might save your
life one day
wouldn't think the thing
you